you used as an illustrative example one
of my favorite stories from history
which is Darwin's marriage and how he
how he went through that and I've got a
little description that I took out the
first book I ever learned about it in
which was the moral Animal by Robert
Wright from 1993. so in the decade of
Darwin's marriage the 1830s the number
of British couples filing for divorce
averaged four per year
[Laughter]
that's not in thousands that's just four
four
I mean the population will be a bit
lower but it's not it's the marriage is
significantly lower than the population
is lower so uh Darwin the uh ever the
rationalist and the self-assessor he was
a man that seemed to be quite um
troubled with uh his own motivations I
think he was his degree of analysis and
attention and assessment of other
creatures also got turned inward on
himself too uh and he journals he
journaled very frequently so it meant
that he has this journal which we now
have access to and he is trying to make
this decision about whether to marry or
not the document has two columns one
labeled marry one labeled not marry and
above them circled other words this is
the question on the pro marriage side of
the equation were children if it pleased
God constant companion and friend in old
age who will feel interested in one
object to be beloved and played with
after reflection of an unknown length he
modified the foregoing sentence with
that better than a dog anyhow
he continued home and someone to take
care of the house charms of music and
female chitchat these things good for
one's Health but terrible loss of time
without warning Darwin had from the
pro-marriage column swerved
uncontrollably into major anti-marriage
factors so major that he underlined it
this issue the infringement of marriage
on his time especially his work time was
addressed at greater length in the
appropriate not to marry column not
marrying he wrote Would preserve freedom
to go where one likes choice of society
and little of it conversation of clever
men at clubs not forced to visit
relatives and to Bent in every trifle to
have the expense and anxiety of children
perhaps quarreling loss of time cannot
read in the evening fatness and idleness
anxiety and responsibility less money
for books and if many children forced to
gain one's bread what an unbelievable
example of somebody trying to use those
Frameworks in order to come up with a
big life decision
yeah uh what I suggest
first point of course is as I argue is
that if you look at those two columns
it's pretty clear what the right choice
is uh not enough time to read do your
work and missing the clever conversation
in clubs with with men uh and what do
you get in return female Chit Chat and
something that's better than a dog
anyhow it's
thin soup uh it's pretty clear that the
right choice for Darwin is not to marry
and underlying of course all that loss
of time I think is his word that he will
not achieve his scientific Legacy
Kafka by the way as as I recount in the
book makes a similar list and he decides
not to marry which is very rational
based on his list but Darwin despite his
list marries and at the end of having
made those two columns he then writes
this stream of Consciousness paragraph
which is basically oh my God I'll be
alone in my old age coming back to a
Digi apartment Mary Mary and he's
marries and he marries I think about six
months later mayor's cousin uh and he um
I don't think she was planned as the
person in the back of his mind I think
he just went out and found her footnote
fascinating
um she would read to him every night and
he actually liked it so even though he
wasn't doing his own reading at night he
did get uh
he did come to like the alternative that
he was able to have through marriage but
the question is what was he thinking
there I mean in the calm sober light of
day he puts up the costs and the
benefits and it's pretty clear marriage
is a loser
but it Bears anyway and I think you know
there's a lot of things you could say
about that decision you know you could
argue social norms kind of pushed him in
that direction I'm sure they did but I
like to think and what what I expanded
on the book I like to think that he
understood there was more at stake than
the day-to-day pleasures of and pains of
of married life
um there was meaning and there was
satisfactions he could only imagine and
he really couldn't imagine because he
had no access to them he surely knew no
one articulate about marriage who could
explain it to him he might have read a
great novel he could have read Jane
Austen and maybe if he did I don't know
if he read Austin but and I think she'd
already written sensibility say or other
books by that time but didn't really
have who's going to explain it and think
about your own for those who out there
who are married I'd explain to someone
what's good and bad about marriage the
bad's pretty clear most people I think
could list what's bad about marriage
like like Darwin was worried about the
downside he had really no access to the
upside the same would be to her children
from the outside children looks like
pretty
bad decisions I mean really
all the expense and the time and the
nuisance and they get sick and they're
worried about this they would die and
and they did
um it's hard
and yet most people have children is is
that irrational or is there something
else going on there and I think the
certainly the
until you've had children your access to
the inner life of Parenthood is limited
uh it's not for everybody it's not like
it's a day at the park it's not uh but
it adds a texture to your life that is
unattainable and other very difficult to
attain I would say it other ways it adds
a meaningfulness and a purpose of just a
life and I think Darwin probably
understood that somewhere when they
didn't write it down maybe not what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
base
[Music]